foreign
[Music]
welcome to pillpod I don't know what
number we're on but
pills isn't here he's indisposed so it's
just Eric and I with I guess long time
contributor somewhat frequent guest lit
Vic Victor welcome hey guys we're taking
a little break from Theory and doing
literature obviously and uh specifically
I guess analyzing the fairy tale to a
certain extent
and for this episode I'm gonna let
actually Victor just kind of introduce
and talk about what it is we read Victor
what are we doing here yeah so uh long
time viewers and listeners might be
aware yeah so pills did a video recently
on the Barbie movie actually which is
coming out this weekend and we thought
it might be fun to actually in
anticipation of that movie take a look
back at you know some of the broader
questions around
um these idealized feminine beauty
standards things like that like the
production of these kinds of images from
Hollywood and even from Disney
specifically because alongside with
Barbie I think Disney is really kind of
like Central to this industry of like
you know the idealized feminine beauty
image and things like that and you can't
really talk about that stuff without
sort of thinking about fairy tales a bit
because so much of what Disney has done
and this whole like in Industry kind of
goes back to these older European
stories so that's what we're kind of
checking out this week in literature
slash Theory corner is um some of these
really Primal fairy tales and especially
thinking about the ways in which uh
stories like Snow White maybe like Red
Riding Hood how they've still they're
still obviously very popular in pop
culture and stuff like that they're
really ubiquitous because they kind of
have these images and narratives which
everyone is familiar with to some extent
you know you think of the image of like
you know the Disney Princess or like the
stories Central to these fairy tales
like they're very sort of well known and
that's something that is still being
ripped on not just like with Disney but
even in like advertising you might see
or like in general in like pop cultures
to pick up on one thing about like the
Barbie video that pills made too that I
think maybe I'll map on to our
discussion is like for those who haven't
watched it or to like remind those who
have one of the points that pills makes
is kind of like
oh like but Barbie was kind of this this
like simultaneous like Perfect Image
that was like sexy but sexless and it
was kind of an idealized image and then
he was kind of of course he made the
video before seeing the movie or he just
saw the trailers and he was like but
I'll bet this movie is going to be about
you know Nuance to the story right it's
gonna show that oh maybe like she has to
come to reality and her like Barbie
world isn't and it's gonna be like some
kind of riff-on complicating some
idealized story of like Barbie is an
ideal image of femininity and I think
maybe some of the stuff we're reading
today is sort of doing the same like
doing something similar with like the
Disney idealized version of the of like
the Disney princess and then kind of
like with that story a little
bit which I don't know up here I was
reading some of the reviews of the
Disney movie and based on those reviews
at least yeah sorry yeah the Barbie
movie based on those reviews it seems
like pills's predictions in the video
are kind of correct but we'll see I
haven't seen it so maybe I'm talking on
my ass but just one time yeah and as as
far as the Barbie film goes like they
the reviews so far they do mention that
like it goes as far as it can for like a
mainstream Hollywood film like it's
trying to sort of like push the
boundaries but it's still it's not going
to totally like go like oh Mulholland
Drive on Barbie or something but but
yeah that that's what's really cool
because yeah Disney has sort of in
parallel been doing something similar
over the last like couple of years like
you guys are all probably familiar with
movies like Maleficent and stuff like
that where they're they're not just like
remaking these older animated films and
live action but they're sometimes trying
to like retell this story in a more edgy
like dark adult way to kind of like you
could say cynically just cash in on the
franchise but also maybe to sort of like
keep up with changing you know like
times and kind of changing attitudes
towards they're older much more sort of
traditional takes on like you know
feminine representation and stuff like
that so
yeah there's there's a lot of cool stuff
to un unpack here that way and I guess
like it's worth mentioning so the the
main story that we're looking at this
week is the classic Snow White story so
this was like also the the fairy tale
that Disney made into their first
animated movie all the way back in the
1930s and it's kind of the one that he
started the whole industry of like you
know Disney Princesses this idealized
kind of image of femininity and stuff
kind of like with Barbie again
attractive but also like sexless kind of
like this ambiguous you know young woman
she's almost like still a teenager but
she's of marriageable age so that's a
sort of foundation for everything that
Disney Then does in like the following
decades and kind of brings us up to the
present and um I guess we can start by
thinking about like Disney's take on
Snow White first because the story that
we actually are looking at is the sort
of Darker version of that it's it's Neil
gaiman's story a snow glass and apples
and it goes in a sort of much darker
Direction it's kind of like trying to
put like an anti-disney reading yeah
before we go there I was wondering if
it's worse as a kind of illiterate in
the sense of not engaging with
literature seriously I've never read the
original fairy tales right so I don't I
only know the Disney version
so I don't know if it's worth maybe
talking about what was the original was
it Grim story of of Snow White or or was
it someone else important note too uh
Disney is currently working on a
live-action Snow White remake as well so
this this is also uh anticipating
something else yeah
um but no that's a good idea like
stepping back and describing um what
what the relevance of this stuff is on
say like a philosophy and critical
theory podcast because um you know we
we've been through the academic kind of
route to getting to know
this stuff some of us and uh you know
you have to learn about these sort of
broad traditions of oral storytelling
that go on say for us it's going to be
in the Middle Ages early modern period
where these stories were being passed
down as Folk Tales and folk Legends very
different from ancient mythology and
sort of as myth as a story form a fairy
tale as a story form contains a more
domestic kind of story set in a
supernatural kind of context or a
context with anthropomorphized animals
um sort of magical creatures sometimes
kind of deformed and monstrous human
beings
and one of the things I guess that's
really interesting about reading this
stuff is is actually a lot like myth
they tend to balance opposites right
like you have these even just the image
of white and Purity versus the image of
red and blood and sexuality right those
are are sort of opposites that are held
in tension whereas when it comes to
things like the Barbie movie which uh
and and any if you've ever seen that
show the toys that made us is that what
it's called the toys that made us you
sort of learn how it's become more of an
industry thing right like from Star Wars
to Lego to Barbie uh the movies are
actually functioning more as like
advertisements for merchandise rather
than like stories they're also
advertising they make money that way so
they tend to you know
I guess with a figure like Barbie right
they they will construct a narrative
Malibu Barbie right often when they go
back to these idealized feminine
qualities but they remove those kinds of
like tensions and ambiguities and inner
and outer conflict between opposing that
they just become these sort of perfect
one-sided desirable
images of human beings Barbie or isn't
it also more of a sanitized opposition
between like good versus evil that's
just like really simplistic sure and
that's Disney's business too was the
original story more nuanced
well no The Original Stories are usually
quite
um simple in structure as far I mean
maybe maybe uh lit vickle can correct me
on this but they're usually quite simple
on structure right if you learn about
this is the connection I want to make
with critical theory because a lot of
ideas and critical theory have been
forged through close reading of
literature and so starting with say the
study of folk Traditions going back to
grim
and then the academic study which seems
to come out of Russia quite a lot with
people like Vladimir prop and the the
semiotics tradition
um like with the way they study like you
know they notice that oh why does
everything happen in threes in fairy
tales for instance right three seems to
be a significant psychologically and
narratively and like you know you look
at the narrative structure and then you
can sort of look at I don't know
whatever popular culture and see how
those structures kind of repeat
themselves in advertising and every day
life people trying to convince you to do
or or tell you things right you see
these sorts of narrative structures
popping up and especially in Barbie and
I I presume in this new uh this new
live-action Snow White movie where one
of the uh headlines is uh the Remake
replaces dwarves with magical creatures
it's the decision this to buy the studio
to push and promote inclusivity so
they're going to um remove the the
dwarves so they're not going to go the
Time Bandits route with this one I guess
yeah and that's so interesting too
because the the dwarves were actually
emphasized in the original Disney movie
by Disney they're not actually that
Central yeah they're put in there and
then removed
yeah so Disney's really trying to keep
up with the times but yeah you're
absolutely right Eric that you know like
a lot of these stories kind of have
really deep sort of psychoanalytical
roots there there's they're they're very
simplistic but the the the social and
kind of domestic themes that they touch
on are really kind of like they run very
deeply especially in European culture
but there's no single kind of like
original version of these stories of
like Snow White or red riding hood or
any of them they they were sort of just
like folk tales as Eric has mentioned
which were common in many different like
countries and or places and we know we
we know a lot of them at least from the
Grimm Brothers so they they're kind of
the ones who are most well known in the
19th century in Germany who collected a
lot of these folk tales because this was
around the time when Germany was kind of
being unified right it wasn't yet like a
single nation state and academics like
the Grimm Brothers were interested in
just collecting folk tales kind of
standardizing the culture the language
they also worked on a German dictionary
so this was really kind of an academic
Pursuit for them and they wanted to just
sort of figure out like what does it
even mean to be German right what does
it mean to kind of be a member of like
the Volk the the people of this new
country and that's where Fairy Tales
come in because they were seen as like
this kind of you know like cultural code
that you know people told among
themselves in the countryside it was it
was like the most authentic version of
the German spirit so that's where the
Grimm Brothers kind of got their own
impetus for like sort of the academic
collection of folk tales and fairy tales
and what's interesting is like these
weren't originally stories meant for
children like they've kind of been
dismissed more recently you know
especially like with Disney's
involvement as like just being stories
for kids but they were originally kind
of you know darker more violent kind of
just stories that were passed around the
campfire basically over many centuries
and that's kind of where the Grimm
Brothers sort of you know present their
versions of them in the 19th century and
then Disney comes along of course in the
20th century and they as we talked about
they totally sanitize them they
Americanized them they kind of shift the
emphasis in certain ways but um these
stories again they go back much further
than Disney even further than the Grimm
Brothers in terms of the sort of themes
that they kind of touch on and that the
tensions that they sort of explore in a
lot of these things so the Grimm
Brothers actually just took basically
what were like oral traditions and put
them into like a collection
again someone coming from someone who's
like you you too have a money collected
them uh you you two are are much more
literate than me I think both of you
have no but that that that's the great
thing Victor is like yeah like even like
anybody would know like recognize these
stories or either like their narratives
or the image especially because it's
been so like oversaturated by Disney
especially you know like if you think of
Snow White you probably think of the
Disney Princess you know you no longer
think of like oh just some generic
character from a grim fairy tale like
this stuff has become like a modified in
a way that like even if you're not
familiar with like the lore or like the
historical context as we are maybe but
like you still know these stories
they're like one some of the most
universal stories because of the way
that they've been kind of commodified
and really interesting ways by Disney
and uh stuff like that yeah one one of
the interesting things too is well one
you mentioned yeah they became stories
for kids I think originally they were
called children's stories because they
were about children many many times they
in included children but the content was
very dark and then at some point it
switched over and they became stories
for kids and then we get the whole
Disney catalog what originally yeah they
just included children quite often and
another thing is
um when you're looking at these stories
it kind of seems weird at first you know
you just read them I mean if you're new
to literary studies you know you just
read them you enjoy them whatever but
once you start reading a lot of them and
and digging into the sort of quote
unquote originals and by Originals I
mean the ones that the Grimm Brothers
found and gave to us uh you'll find the
same story form but with characters
switched there is a version of Snow
White with a male protagonist and and
there's there's a lot of the time
they'll preserve the basic structure of
the narratives and the archetypes but
they might switch them around switch
genders or or change some significant
detail in them and give the story a new
name and a kind of a new meaning but
when you compare them they have these
structural similarities and so the study
of folk tales and fairy tales actually
inspired a lot of structuralism which is
still very very popular today even in a
kind of attenuated attenuated
post-structuralist form although the
impetus for the development of some a
lot of structuralist theories it comes
from looking at yeah the the overall
structures and patterns that you can be
Discerning in folks narratives and then
what that can tell about the culture
because a good reading of these stories
also opens up and and makes connections
and and makes the story very rich
because like you said the stories
themselves are very simple in structure
but once you start kind of getting into
the images and the symbols and tracing
them back to where they came from that's
when the reading starts to open up and
become very rich so just reading these
stories interesting fun kind of quaint
or exotic and once you start to sort of
study them and look at broader patterns
you start to realize hey there's
something more you know we can actually
learn something about people by reading
these things and learn something about
ourselves today and in so far as we
continue to repeat these stories but we
select certain ones we selected Snow
White over the male version could you
give us a rundown of like the original
uh Snow White story kind of just like
because I think most people will know
the Disney version
and maybe yeah so just give a quick
rundown and maybe like if you have it
handy like kind of a specific attention
to things that are like pretty different
from the Disney version it's very short
yeah it's very short at its core it's
sort of like the Disney version is
fairly faithful in in terms of like the
main plot it just kind of like gets to
this question of uh competition between
different generations of women right so
you have the young Princess Snow White
and her mother dies giving basically
birth to her so there's already this
question of an absent mother and the
stepmother steps in and she's the evil
older Queen and she basically wants to
get rid of Snow White because as we all
know you know there's the classic sort
of construct of the the magic mirror and
the queen asks her mayor you know who is
the fairest of them all there's this
question of Beauty and the idealized
beauty standard and the mirror
eventually says well you are very fair
you are very beautiful but Snow White is
becoming more fair more beautiful and
that's when the queen decides all right
I have to kill this younger more
beautiful princess because she is now
appropriating something that should
belong to me so there's that's basically
the core of the story is they're not
related did
they're not they're not related in the
original story like is it is it from a
previous marriage of the king or
something I forget like that detail
that's actually interesting I think in
the original story it is potentially her
actual mother but the Grim sorry the
Disney one makes her the stepmother so
it's a little bit more like you know you
can still have that conflict between the
generations but it's not directly her
the mother on daughter violence yeah oh
so that's one of the changes for example
that Disney would make yeah but
interestingly
um yeah so the evil queen we call her
evil of course she's a villain in the
story we she kind of then tries all
these ways to get rid of Snow White you
know of course she sends the Huntsman
after her Huntsman brings back a heart
says that it's the Snow White's heart
it's actually you know the heart of a
deer or something that he kills because
he can't bring himself to actually kill
this young girl and the queen eats the
heart and she's satisfied all right this
this is done I've won the competition
I've won the beauty contest I am the
fairest of them all but of course like
she asks the mirror again so who's the
fairest of them all and the mirror this
magical thing that cries you know Snow
White is still out there she is still
fairer than you so what are you going to
do about that so the queen is just you
know Furious and that's when she devises
her scheme to kind of you know go in
Disguise looking for Snow White she goes
off in the woods and she finds her
living with these dwarves and she at
this point the queen is in Disguise
she's dressed as an old woman selling
apples she actually tries several things
but the most famous trick she pulls is
selling her the Apple this magic
poisoned apple and Snow White of course
you know she's very young naive gullible
she trusts this older woman she eats the
apple and she gets poisoned and she
basically dies in the original version
and in the Disney version too it's very
morbid the dwarves put her in this glass
coffin and it's only when this magical
Prince comes along and sees this kind of
like you know comatose dead princess in
the coffin and he thinks wow there's
something really attractive here I want
to like kiss this person then and that
brings Snow White back to life and of
course you know happily ever after in
the original Grimm story The Queen shows
up at their wedding and she's killed by
wearing like some hot shoes or something
because it's very strange and violent
like you know the dance to death uh
she's basically yeah she basically like
Burns to death so like all good witches
do you know oh wow that's and I guess
that aspect is brought back in the in
the rethink in the retelling in a way oh
definitely yeah so we'll get to Neil
Gaiman too because he has a lot of fun
with this but uh yeah in the Disney
version the queen also dies but she just
has like the classic Disney death of
falling off a cliff or whatever you know
you don't actually see her die but right
essentially yeah like so Disney does
kind of follow the same basic pattern as
the traditional story but they tone down
the violence a bit they make the queen a
little bit less directly related with
Snow White and they also emphasize a lot
more of like the you know the cued kind
of you know Side characters like the
animals in the forest or like the
dwarves especially as Eric was saying
you know so they already kind of like
set their brand with with this like
movie in the 30s in terms of like it's
this really kind of like beautiful and
animated feature it was actually very
successful not just because it was very
well told as a story but because of like
the animation technology like that's why
people actually were so interested in
seeing this movie it was kind of like
almost like the Avatar of its time you
could say because like nobody had done a
full-length animated feature before and
people were actually skeptical like is
anybody really gonna sit through like 90
minutes of like animation and Disney
proved them all wrong it was like it was
really successful and it kind of just
started the whole you know Disney Empire
from that point so yeah there's lots of
interesting ways in which the the idea
of Snow White like the image becomes so
Central to Disney's sort of like further
evolution of their fairy tale films and
like the whole industry of you know like
Disney World and Disneyland and even
today you know you can go there and have
your photo taken with you know somebody
dressed up as snow white or like any of
the other you know canonical Disney
princesses by this point there's been so
many versions of this but that that's
kind of where it all started where like
this massive you know corporation that
has kind of set the tone for like beauty
standards and femininity and all these
things it all kind of goes back to this
movie in the 30s Snow White and then the
Grim story that it kind of was Loosely
adapting at that time so in the original
like I guess in all of the versions I
think right like the the king died or
some for some reason is that right and
then and then it's just the evil
stepmother the king's kind of just
absent it seems right he's he's not even
there in the in the original version
um well you got to think in terms of of
roles first of all so that the mother
dies when when Snow White is born but
then there's a the second Queen comes
into play and she's sort of you know you
can read that as the first queen
transforming into the second Queen and
then being the same person so there's
already a kind of ambiguity toward in
words is she the daughter is Snow White
the stepdaughter she's kind of both in a
weird way like does she represent
something about this new Queen yeah she
does she represents a kind of internal
element that the new Queen is is kind of
trying to cut away or or work against
but then and the new Queen is is I mean
the classic yes evil stepmother Trope
but she's also
kind of struggling against she's also
providing a foil for Snow White's own
struggle because Snow White is pure and
innocent and on the sort of threshold of
of Womanhood and the queen presents this
foil of the kind of active artistic
plotting creative Woman versus the more
idealized type of Snow White if the
passive innocent submissive kind of very
contemplative and and very pure and
non-active woman and so there's kind of
a an inversion you know the the the evil
queen and her inner kind of Innocence
she's trying to cut out and then the
Snow White and her kind of this kind of
um promise of an act of taking control
of your life
um thing she's trying to avoid that and
be kind of pure innocent so there's you
can kind of read it like that yeah
sometimes those details about like who's
who is she the stepmother is she the
mother it's not it's not super important
when you're trying to get like an
interpretation on his feet on that point
just to clarify I I do think that
actually even in the original Grim
version her mother dies giving birth to
her and we we're dealing with a
stepmother even there so yeah sometimes
it is the direct mother but in this case
yes yeah and as soon as a child was born
the queen died a year later the king
took himself another wife she was a
beautiful woman proud and arrogant she
could not stand it if anyone might
surpass her beauty she had a magic
mirror so you see you know if if we're
just noticing those details right like
the first queen is sitting it framed by
a window uh a CL a window a frame of
black ebony wood the author is careful
to tell us and then the second Queen has
a magic mirror which is like a window
it's a framing device except this one is
a transparent uh object with an internal
kind of right what's Through the Looking
Glass right versus just kind of out a
window but these women are are framed in
a certain way right and the second Queen
is her struggle is now kind of set up as
this internal struggle she's looking out
a window but it's a mirror she's looking
into herself and she has a male voice
telling her about herself and her beauty
right so it sets up this kind of
struggle between yeah femininity and
patriarchy on the one side and
femininity and its internal
contradictions on the other side some
interesting uh context too for like the
reason why you that the figure of the
stepmother would actually be quite
common in these older stories is because
like the reason that like the husband
might take a new wife is because the
first wife is obviously dead right and
the way that that happened most often
was because they would die in childbirth
because that was much more common like
before the 20th century historically
even in Germany even in Europe so
stepmothers were quite common in that
way and that's why like they show up in
a lot of these older stories and that's
also where some of these like tensions
come from because like the stepmother
like she's not actually like
biologically related to her stepdaughter
at that point so like yeah you know
they're they're technically family she's
married to the husband but it's a little
bit of a tricky dynamic because you know
there's a question of inheritance
there's a question of like you know
who's the husband gonna pay most
attention to like again it kind of gets
back to the patriarchal you know like
context this is all being staged in but
that's where you see like those tensions
are already like historically present
and it's like they're very sort of like
ready to be taken to these dramatic
places in a fairy tale it's like let's
look at a story where the stepmother
tries to kill the stepdaughter you know
that's the sort of you know that's where
it all comes from is the competition
basically at that point in a patriarchal
system between the older woman and the
younger kind of daughters so even though
again like this is all fairy tale fantas
see the actual historical social issues
that it's exploring are very grounded
they're very much a product of the times
that these stories were being written or
told out loud yeah it's been a long time
too but does the Disney version seems to
tell it more from Snow White's
perspective too that I mean we do get a
lot of sort of the queen we get enough
of the queen to understand what she's up
to and what the action of the story is
but a lot of it is is Snow White kind of
running around in the woods in the
cartoon right like making friends with
animals they emphasize this Attunement
with nature in the more innocence right
right where we you don't eat animals and
dominate nature women go into nature and
are at Harmony with it kind of thing uh
and yeah that so they change the
perspective quite a bit as well as the
ending
doesn't do that he actually maintains
the same perspective as the original
which is very interesting yeah yeah Neil
Gaiman does something really cool and
well I think once we kind of finish
fully setting up the Disney version with
you guys have to consider how he
subverts all of this because you're
right Eric you pointed out that um
there's a really sharp contrast drawn
between the kinds of women that Snow
White and the queen are supposed to
represent right or like Snow White it's
like literally in her name she's like
you know fair and virginal and pure and
like all the kinds of idealized
qualities Associated like not just in
the 19th century with a young woman but
even I think when Disney is making their
adaptation like Disney himself is very
much kind of like presenting this as the
ideal sort of like young feminine beauty
standard even for the 20th century and
then in contrast the older Queen the
stepmother She's Not Just older but she
she's actually a lot smarter she's
powerful she has like she knows like
certain she has magical knowledge you
know she's able to kind of like create
the magic Apple
try to like trick Snow White and all
these things and there's actually some
famous scenes like in the movie where
she's working in her lab and she's kind
of actually like figuring out how to
make this poison how to turn herself
into like an older woman to disguise
herself so it's a really clear contrast
here between like all right this like
young innocent naive sweet girl with
Snow White and then the older much more
powerful much more intelligent but
therefore much more dangerous and
clearly villainous kind of woman in the
queen and that's something like I think
you know if you think about a lot of
fairy tales and like Disney films like
usually the villain is an older woman
like that's the pattern you know the
heroine is a young you know naive girl
or young woman and it's the older woman
who is usually cast in the villain's
role and that's something that I think
like it's we we almost like we we
underestimate how much Disney has sort
of perpetuated that notion of like watch
out for the older woman with magical
powers because she's probably gonna you
know she's the villain in in the story
she's she's the one that you have to
kind of watch out for as opposed to the
older male figure who sometimes you know
out you know you can trust him more than
you can trust maybe the older witch you
know yeah so you can think of there
being two basic archetypes of the woman
there then the kind of angelic woman and
the monster woman or the Monstrous and
the Angelic right and so Snow White is
obvious it's obvious which one she's
supposed to be and the it's it's weird
because the angelicness is threatened at
the um approach to Womanhood because
that's when that this is the the
menstruation bleeding aspect of it
uh which gets you know the the symbolic
coming of age
thing where where your Snow White Purity
and and and the opposite kind of red
blood of loss of Innocence becomes a
kind of huge you know point of passage
could say in in any in anybody's life
growing up where they have to be uh
going through this monthly uh period of
you know this internal natural clock
kind of thing and so drama it kind of
dramatizes that always
kind of danger of going from Angelic
innocence to a kind of monstrous
worldliness or you know like the coming
of age when a woman in these stories
starts to exercise seduction starts to
exercise agency that often gets marked
as a kind of danger zone right because
in these stories women are supposed to
be passive and submissive so when they
start to you know show gleamings of of
understanding the world or taking
control of their situation they're
immediately kind of coded as as in
danger of becoming a monster or going
through some sort of struggle and that's
what kind of that's like represents Snow
White's struggle with this stepmother
this this kind of monstrosity of this
woman and the older that they get the
more kind of dangerous and monstrous
they are because as you point out
totally Eric like they're also past
childbearing age past a certain point
right so in the more patriarchal kind of
perspective it's like well not only do
older women they've they've learned too
much over over their years but they're
also they've kind of like you know gone
past their function in terms of you know
bearing children and kind of like
raising them so the queen is bad enough
but then when the queen turns into like
the older woman who tricks Snow White
that's like you know that's when she's
really kind of most dangerous most
suspicious in this sort of patriarchal
context yeah and like exactly and also
the specifically the fact that the
reason that you would become so angry is
like this like because you're not as
beautiful it's like the most in a way
like very anti-feminist story in the
sense that like of course the thing
that's going to make a woman evil is
like her obsession with beauty right
like that's obviously going to be the
thing totally yeah yeah so that's a
feminist story but it's not like
critical feminism like we would think of
today it's not critical yeah and we see
like beauty isn't just Beauty in terms
of oh you know aesthetic vanity like
it's a deadly serious question like who
is the fairest of them all like it
determines who lives and dies basically
right because within this patriarchal
system like beauty is currency beauty is
the way that you rise to the top and you
stay there and that's what like it so
it's it becomes kind of a metaphor this
is kind of lost a little bit in the
Disney movie but it beauty is a code for
much more than just Aesthetics it's a
question of power it's a question of you
know like Prestige and this goes back
like even all the way to Greek mythology
where you know a lot of the greatest
conflicts are set off because of like a
goddess thinking that Immortal is more
beautiful than her and she can't have
that and she has to kill that mortal
because it's not just about like it's
not just her vanity it's like this is
who she is it represents the core of
like her power in a way that she has to
control so this is something like
obviously today you know we there's all
kinds of like questions around beauty
standards and everything but we still
have this sort of thing where like
there's a Code around beauty that
actually represents much more than just
you know like appearance or like
Aesthetics there's a deeper underlying
significance to it yeah which in a way
has like some truth to it like and has
in the sense for sure yeah that's still
a currency I mean when you look when you
think about like the images of Instagram
and all this stuff like I think the
reason why
people and especially like younger women
become so fixated on these things is
because there is like a perceived power
to being like this object of desire and
I think it's so fascinating too
especially with things like Instagram
and social media that like it's more of
a currency than ever because it's
actually something you can transform
into a product yeah literally like with
a selfie or with whatever and that
actually can translate into like you
know more hits more you know more money
actually you know so it's at like it's
this whole question of like Beauty as
currency is actually being borne out
even more so like nowadays where you can
sort of like literally monetize looks in
certain ways and you know Tick Tock and
all kinds of stuff like that so yeah we
we'd like to think these are really
archaic kind of you know folk tales and
these older standards like they're
actually very present even today these
questions yeah what's what's really uh
just as a point of contrast that kind of
really brings out something specific
about the Snow White setup too is we did
look at another version of Little Red
Riding Hood which has a similar kind of
provenance as the Snow White story and
Little Red Riding Hood is the same sort
of thing right like this passage into
womanhoods the oncoming of the bleeding
and the and and the the Wolves and the
forest kind of thing there's there's
that kind of aspect but notice there's
no queens involved in this story this is
this is rural life so this is a
coming-of-age story set like at the edge
of the woods in a kind of very humble
setting and so the the struggle is not
between
um the mother and the daughters a little
red but it's actually between you know
her and the kind of whatever the wolves
are taken to represent in the woods
right the this deceit this dangerousness
this nothing is kind of what it seems
when you're out in the woods kind of
thing and you can't be taken in by
gullibility because that's as as a young
woman if you step off the path the kind
of metaphor right and so she has to get
to her grandmother's house but then a
big deception happens there right and we
know that there's many different endings
that have been stuck onto that and you
can even look at the variations when
they come and what they are trying to do
with the story but the point is yeah
it's it's a big contrast this isn't this
isn't like a um in Snow White we can say
you know okay well there's an anxiety
over you know being replaced by the
younger fitter childbearing woman but
here that that fear is is is is is not
present it's a fear of more of the
outside of the unknown of the of the
what's next kind of thing both of them
have that temporalization of fear where
you know eventually I'm going to get old
and since men are kind of excluded from
this whole cycle uh he's my husband's
gonna want a new wife or or something
like that whereas in Red Riding Hood
it's it's it's different right it's
about meeting boys and hunters and scary
wolves and and it just it provides an
interesting contrast just just if you
think the succession of the the anxiety
over Youth and beauty is is limited to
the upper echelons of society it's it's
they can tell it at different social
levels as well and all of these are
ultimately becoming of age stories yeah
you're absolutely right Eric because
like they they they're usually about
FEMA protagonists you know and they're
usually about women who kind of like are
taking their first steps into the world
you know whether it's the Dark Forest or
you know the intrigues at court you know
with the evil queen but it's the ways in
which for Red Riding Hood certainly like
she's being told to sort of like toe the
line and stick to a certain path and not
wander off and explore things in the
woods and I mean you know you've got
like Freud all over that like what is
she being told to not explore right what
is the actual danger that her parents
are telling her to not pursue this this
young girl with her Red Cap right I mean
so there's a lot of there's some
underlying sexual elements especially in
a story like that which I think as we've
seen like a lot of authors especially
nowadays are like really interested in
bringing out and making more explicit
and emphasizing like you know what these
stories are ultimately kind of like
toying with you know what are the
anxieties that they're kind of touching
on so I don't know do we maybe want to
consider the Neil Gaiman take on this
because
what we've been we've been circling here
yes Neil Gaiman does some interesting
stuff with this story I I didn't
actually expect to enjoy it as much as I
did but it was quite a fun it was really
quite a fun read yeah yeah just kind of
waiting for the Snow White references to
pop in there and then how they kind of
come in is so really interesting right
because you know it starts out the same
kind of way as the original we're kind
of looking at things it's mid-winter
which again before before you continue
is it was the original also written from
the Stepmother's perspective or is that
a new anneal gaming thing no no it
starts with her right like the first
word spoken in the Grim version uh is if
I if only I had a child as white as snow
as red as blood and as black as as the
wood in this Frame right that was the
the first the first queen says and does
it stay in that this birth and dies yeah
and then it switches to the second Queen
and it's her asking the mirror then
sending the hunter out then her coming
back after that fails and making the
poison comb and then the Apple like it
all all kind of comes back to her
perspective but to your point uh Victor
uh it's not told in first person in the
Grim version
yeah it's like once upon a time there
was a queen the rest happened you're
right yeah so what what
yeah it's a limited third person
perspective right so it's from her
perspective but it's told in the third
person this is an interesting thing that
Gaiman does right that he he tells the
story
from and you get you get the whatever
quote-unquote evil Stepmother's stream
of Consciousness like that's the whole
story right it's her like yeah you get I
it's it's in the first person she says I
am this uh yeah so it's not told in the
third person yeah that's another that
that's more technical yeah the person
changes but the perspective is the same
right it's both from her perspective I
could you could say you can have a third
person from a character's perspective
still you just call it like a limited
third person or something like that
right yeah I think you're right though
Victor because yeah Neil Gaiman is
deliberately kind of subverting at least
what we take as the Disney version of
the story because in the in in his short
story at snow glass and apples he's
telling the story from the Queen's
perspective and he's actually painting
the queen as the hero as a victim by the
end but as a hero who kind of like you
know she marries the king she inherits
you know I guess she becomes stepmother
to this young girl Snow White the the
Snow White character and she realizes
pretty soon that there's something wrong
with this child well that like Snow
White is actually really evil in
Neil gaiman's version and the queen has
to kind of like deal with this really
monstrous threatening child so yeah
maybe you can say a little bit more
about you know what happens or how she
kind of you know discovers all of that
yeah we're we're introduced to not not
in such a matter-of-fact way as the
original one you know first one wants a
wife or a child has one dies gets us and
then the king gets a new wife and this
one yeah it's much more from her
perspective she says you know this this
blonde-haired king with a big red bronze
beard took me and and well this is one
of the very explicit sexual content in
in gaimans which is because
a stylistic departure of of his devising
yeah and uh and then suddenly she she
kind of just says oh he already has a
daughter like she he seduced her brought
her home with them and there's a
daughter there and she's she says or or
it's narrated that his daughter was only
a child no more than five years of age
when I came to the Palace a portrait of
her dead mother hung in the princess's
Tower room a tall woman hair the color
of dark wood eyes not brown so you can
see that there's Neil Gaiman tying them
together right in in this different way
though because it's much more from the
Stepmother's perspective where she's
seduced she's brought it oh there's
already like a daughter here and she's
kind of weird she won't eat with us we
don't see her very much
and then and then she's got this very
monstrous appearance too she's like Neil
Gaiman just makes Snow White into a
freaking monster that's I guess
she should have said a while back
he he basically plays with the idea of
this young child like you know woman
having pale skin and you know black hair
and sharp yellow teeth yes she basically
like reads Snow White as a vampire right
that's what that that's what the queen
realizes and that's what she has to you
know like get rid of because this
creature is a threat to her it's a
threat to her kingdom and the rest of
the story is basically like this this
really cool you know how to kill a
vampire 101 you know sort of like set of
steps where the queen does everything
she does in the classic story where
she's trying to hunt down Snow White
kill you know like poison her dude
whatever it takes and every time Snow
White keeps coming back from the dead
basically because she's a vampire like
you have to do very specific things to
get rid of a vampire and that's kind of
what Neil Gaiman is sort of playing with
it's like what what if we reread the the
classic fairy tale as like the queen is
actually the hero and Snow White is this
monster who you know is basically like
keeps coming back from the dead right so
yeah yeah should any of you feel like a
little bit like dubious of the narrator
though
because like they're because there was a
part of me that was like
okay like she's presenting it this way
but could is this just her
rationalization for wanting to kill this
girl like like is it but I don't know I
mean like definitely there were some
stuff in there where you're like okay
this is like obviously playing with the
whole vampire thing but there's another
part of me that was like well that's
that's like a huge you know when you get
into the real specific analysis why does
the stepmother hate snow white becomes a
really theoretically interesting
question because it's like how does she
come to hate her and why it just seems
like her default position is to kind of
hate her uh Neil Gaiman kind of gives us
a way into that though right because
she's like just this new wife uh and
there's this weird girl running around
the castle that her uh new boyfriend
husband is is uh owns and uh so then
when she was six years old she she comes
into the room one day that the that the
new Queen sleeps in
and that says she's hungry and and she
feeds her some apples just not nothing
happening here just feed some apples uh
and then she as she's sort of feeding
the girl the girl Snow White the Neil
gaiman's crazy vampire monster Snow
White starts to chew on her finger it
draws blood and sucks on her finger and
like drinks this blood and and you know
it presents them almost bonding at first
and then suddenly this happens and she
freezes and she and and then and then
this snow white vampire runs off having
drank her blood and then from that
moment on she barricades her room shut
and won't is terrified of this girl so
she's actually like there's an element
of fear beyond the sort of abstract fear
of this girl's gonna replace me one day
there's like an immediate sense of well
you could we could talk about the the
gothic horror elements that's the other
thing Gaiman brings in right Neil Gaiman
brings in Gothic elements explicitly
into this which which is not in fairy
tales don't tend not to have like a a
Gothic stylization that's for more for
like new novels what does that mean like
a Gothic novels like um like like the
the first Gothic novel was written by
Horace Walpole and Ann Radcliffe is
another very famous
there's the castle of atranto by Horace
Walpole there's the the Italian by uh
Ann Radcliffe these the gothic novel is
a specific genre of of
Novel fiction right where with you with
um big bad guys behind the scenes
pulling all the strings and sort of
things that seem Supernatural and
sometimes they're left that way
sometimes they kind of Scooby-Doo them
and reveal that oh there's like somebody
behind the silhouette making it look
like a ghost is there but they're just
classic settings like the dark
mysterious Castle you know the
supernatural lady architecture yeah yeah
passageways and secret tunnels and that
that is present a little bit even in
like classic fairy tales but classic
fairy tales like they're very simply
written it's just like okay this
happened that happened she went here she
went like there's no descriptions really
of like the surroundings whereas yeah
like gothic fiction takes its time like
setting the scene it's like oh you know
the woods were like this there was a
creeping over like it's sort of like
quintessentially like Dark Fantasy sort
of setting and that's something that
yeah Neil Gaiman loves to sort of you
know like use that kind of genre and
he's definitely kind of you know
painting a really kind of sort of like
horrific picture of like this castle
with the queen and like Snow White as a
vampire so yeah I think though coming
back to your point Victor about like um
you know how much are we meant to trust
the Queen's version of all of this I
think that's really interesting because
that's sort of what Neil gaiman's kind
of like inviting us to think about is
like well you know how much of like the
question of like heroes and villains in
a classic story like this is just based
on who's telling the story right like if
you hear from the Queen's perspective
well Snow White was a monster but if you
hear it you know the classic version
well actually you know the queen was a
monster so there's actually a point
where I think um she sort of nods to
that like in the story
there's a quick passage where she says
uh you know
um she's talking about you know they say
this they say that like basically people
who have told this story before will
tell you it was like this and like that
but then she says quote
um you know some say but it is her lie
and not mine that I was given the heart
of Snow White that I ate it these are
lies and half truths that fall like the
snow they cover the things that I
remember the things that I saw
and quote so like she's like gaming is
directly kind of like you know winking
to like you know you might have heard
another version of this story that tells
you that the queen is the bad guy but no
the the queen is here to tell you what
really happens so it's kind of that sort
of you know like a retelling of a story
that everyone knows that has become
quite popular actually like recent years
like again with stuff like Maleficent or
whatever from like revisiting a story
from the villain's point of view and
kind of you know maybe for feminist
reasons maybe just for like you know
cash grab reasons to kind of you know
cash in on you know a familiar story but
that's interesting yeah that that you've
noted Victor that there's already a
question of narrative reliability here
of like how much are we to really
believe yeah as an outsider uh you know
I guess the the impression that you get
when it's one even if it's from a
certain perspective but it's in the
third person there's like a sense of
like objectivity to it where you're like
okay like I'm getting an account of
what's actually happening but then the
moment the story is always from a first
person perspective I think that question
is always open right you're like okay
like how are like this is their
interpretation right they're they're in
they're mediated phenomenological
experience of what's happening and human
beings have Tendencies to rationalize
all kinds of things so that question was
just always in the back of my head it's
like okay Snow White to be like a
vampire but also I don't know there's
just some things like you said like I do
remember that point where she's like you
know you might have heard other versions
of the story and yeah you're definitely
putting your finger on some of the
things that this this first person
device
um some of the things that it lets Neil
Gaiman bring in
um the first person device well first of
all it lets him kind of make her
speculate make the the second Queen the
evil queen quote unquote speculate about
what happens when she lays her trap she
puts the apples out and then she says I
imagine and then she goes on this long
sort of narration about how she imagines
her trap sort of working that's one
thing and then another thing is yeah the
unreliability right like it adds a bit
of cell what we would call
self-reflexivity into the stories right
because the original ones present
themselves as the authoritative version
of the story you'd never see a fairy
tale acknowledging in the story that it
is just one version among others right
that they're not self-reflexive like
that they don't know that they are
stories when you're reading them kind of
thing but then when you read modern
fiction they often have these moments of
clarity about themselves almost when
they kind of hint that they know that
they're a fictional story in a strange
way so that that kind of first person
element again allows these internal this
internal monologue of the queen to make
these speculations and kind of and I
think that made the story bring these
bells in your heads
yeah yeah that there's a lot of
uncertainty about what everyone's
thinking yeah
um what's what was what what do you guys
make of the heart because right that was
one thing that was different right
wasn't there a thing where she like has
the heart and it's
still beating or something on the walls
yeah yeah well that's just sort of I
think like game and riffing with like
the classic vampire Trope of like you
know vampire hunting 101 destroy the
heart don't just take the heart out you
know like cut it up burn it bury it do
do whatever it takes because the idea in
gaiman's version is that okay so she
sends someone after Snow White Snow
White the vampire he brings back her
heart and the queen thinks okay the
nightmare is over I I've defeated this
evil creature I can just hang her heart
up and it's gonna be fine but then she
starts to hear like years later stories
about how you know people have still
seen this creature in the woods and
she's still feeding on people and stuff
and the heart is still beating in her
room and like so she realizes oh no snow
white is still out there I have to do
more I have to go and finish the job
right I have to so that's where it sort
of you know plays into the older fairy
tale of the heart right now yeah so
Queen then disguises herself and goes
after Snow White to sort of give her a
poisoned apple and to make sure that
okay this time she's dead for sure okay
and that actually brings us to the
really sort of morbid ending with the
prince if we want to kind of
psychoanalyze that I got one more thing
about the heart too is because because
it replaces the mirror doesn't it it
beats commercials alive
but but it's the heart oh yeah it tells
her it's in Neil gaiman's version It's
the beating of the heart that tells her
that she is animate right when she is
put into a coma the heart stops beating
and then when she's revived once again
the heart starts beating it kind of
replaces the mirror function with the
heart that's how she knew she was still
alive right she cut the heart out
thought it was done and then over the
years mysteriously
um there's this really important
Festival that happens uh and the uh the
attendance was dwindling over the years
like you know the economy is up
basically because there's this vampire
creature running around in the woods uh
diverting people but the interesting
thing is too A lot of the new money that
they see in the kingdom is from the
forest folk which are like kind of
monstrous semi-barbaric including the
dwarves and and other kind of malformed
and anti-social type of people like you
know the the whole you know criminals
living in the woods kind of thing the
rot kind of like an evil version of
Robin Hood and his merry men I'm just
riffing but yeah so so those people are
also like they have to come in give
their weird ancient money that they find
and buy their weird things and go out
that helps them but now that there's
this sort of vampire running around it's
it's stopping attendance so she knows
that there's something up and the heart
beating is is another then becomes the
symbol of of oh she's still out there
yeah and this is where Neil Gaiman also
goes like really anti-disney with the
way that he talks about the dwarves if
you guys remember they're they're really
kind of just these you know hairy
disgusting creatures one of them at one
point is like pissing on the side of the
road
Disney World so he's really trying to
bring back this element of like yeah
darkness and Gothic mystery to this
world that the story is set in and
especially to the creatures or the
people who are associated with Snow
White in this version you know the
vampire Snow White and the the queen in
this story is really kind of the only
you know sort of sensible sane person
who she's the only one who seems to
understand the the threat posed by the
forest and by Snow White and the people
still harboring her so that's why
so we we actually like learn here she's
so Keen to kind of kill Snow White once
and for all
yeah so it humanizes her right like yeah
because in the beginning too it it tells
after that weird experience she has
initially with uh Snow White the little
princess sucking her the blood out of
her finger and running off
um then then it goes into this narrative
about how her her love the king is
slowly fading into elderliness and and
and uh he's becoming emasculated
basically he can't have sex with her
anymore she and yeah you can't get it up
scene where she tries to like give him a
and he he kind of violently
recoils and he's so like embarrassed and
and it kind of just adds this slow decay
of her husband and it makes it it makes
you feel bad for the queen right because
in the in the Grim version you're kind
of even though Snow White is such a
peripheral character you're kind of
worried about her all of our kind of
empathy is focused on her not the queen
but here it's completely different right
he adds that like she's just been swept
up into this position she's very
beautiful she was once like Snow White
presumably she used to go to these um
festivals I was just mentioning and she
was like a fortune teller and she used
to do it in in pools of ink and water
and Lee tea leaves or whatever and then
she got a mirror and she was able to
accurately tell things through this sort
of looking glass mirror this polished
glass and uh that that's where her power
is is her power to sort of almost help
people in a in a kind of Carnival
fortune teller kind of way and she
people respected her for that it wasn't
like a source of her Terror of of
terribleness yeah that right there gets
back to this question of you know women
with magical powers and how they're
viewed in these kinds of stories right
because in Neil gaiman's version you
know the queen yeah she's got a magic
mirror she's got some spells but she
clearly is somebody who's trying to do
the best things for her kingdom but in
every other version of the story oh no
she's a witch she has magical hours
she's evil automatically and you
actually see in game and Story how
people start to turn against her right
once they learn more about her powers
and about her magic and it's just like
okay by the end it was essentially like
spoiler alert it comes down to burn the
witch right there's something about her
that people don't can't tolerate and
Snow White is at the center of that but
yeah so towards the end it's pretty dark
if you guys remember yeah
yeah that's interesting yeah yeah it
finishes off like a Salem Witch Hunt
almost like she gets kind of burned at
the end and and uh but we don't really
get a sense of closure there do we
because it's like
you know Snow White is Snow White NOW
gonna go through the same sort of thing
she stuffs her heart back into her chest
at the end like a free yeah so maybe
maybe we can just comment on how um in
in gaiman's version Snow White comes
back because like he he sticks pretty
closely to the classic fairy tale where
there's a prince who brings Snow White
back to life basically
and but he's a little different from our
yeah so maybe we can talk about the the
key emphasis yeah being different I mean
in the in the original one
right this this um kind of handsome
prince comes along and and and barters
the dwarves for the uh Sleeping Beauty
right the yeah the Snow White Sleeping
and and uh
and and she he kind of brings her back
and and that's kind of the end of it
right but here it's it's so much
different because this first of all he
heavily characterizes this Hunter
she meets right he's he's kind of this
silver-tongued young guy with is it how
does how do how do they introduce you
I'm trying to find this yeah I don't
know in what's it's the same idea of the
the prince comes across the glass coffin
and but he's actually turned on by what
he sees like it's explicit in Neil
Gaiman right like he wants to you know
get it on with glass cough and Snow
White this and there's some suggestion
that like there's necrophilia involved
in this too which is actually I mean
that's sort of a subtext even in the
original fairy tale where I was gonna
why would this Prince be interested in
making out with this dead girl but here
Gaiman really pushes on that and he says
explicitly no this was a prince who
wanted his women to be like you know
still and kind of um basically dead when
he was sort of having his way with them
so there's that scene as you mentioned
Eric where first he's at the castle he
tries to sort of make love to the queen
and she's sort of too Lively for him and
he runs off humiliated yes here's the
here's the clip uh his manhood slid out
of me I reached out and touched it a
tiny slippery thing so he resembles her
last husband when he was on his deathbed
him in his prime he can't he's he's very
uh not very virile so you know you know
she's still like they he emphasizes that
this this older Queen is still young and
and stupid she made stupid decisions she
only this is this is a huge Gothic Trope
right is is to cut people into pieces
like uh separation disembodiments like
these these things are huge and she says
I was 18. I had her heart cut out what I
should have done was have her drawn and
quartered and have all the pieces burned
until they could blow away like snow
into like and you know burned into ashes
so they could blow away like loose snow
that's like that's almost a paraphrase
uh interesting use of the way heard snow
in there that should bring some Bells
there's a part too where there's a
snowflake on her cheek that doesn't melt
because she's cold yeah she's so cold
she's like a corpse even when she's
walking around yeah so in this part yeah
we're getting to is is um my 25th year
came she says and when my daughter my
stepdaughter had eaten the poison fruit
two Winters back when the prince came to
my Palace that's what this Prince comes
from a neighboring Kingdom and she's
being a queen here she's like well she's
being a queen and a woman first of all
my husband's dead I'm ready to
move on okay second of all an alliance
with this Prince would be a great thing
right our kingdoms would stretch around
this Forest there would still be this
horrible forest in the middle but I we
would have this bit she's being
diplomatic here she sleeps with them she
Charmed but he's he's he's not a very
good guy he's kind of not virile he she
doesn't please him in the right way and
he leaves and he's into corpses
basically yeah yeah he oh yeah that's
the other thing yeah he's like don't
move don't make any noise don't speak
and she gets into it and kind of moans a
bit and he's and and he pulls out he's
like this isn't working for me and
pieces out and goes into the woods with
his retinue right and and then we get
this speculation I am I imagine his
loins have a knot of frustration she
says he's probably riding through the
woods with blue balls all pissed looking
for his next victim yeah that's the
other part of these stories like Neil
Gaiman really loves to just like dwell
on the sexual subtext of the fairy tales
he's just having a lot of fun with it
but it kind of works here because of
course by the end of the story The this
Prince humiliated he finds Snow White in
the glass coffin and he says this is she
can't move this is just the kind of girl
I've been looking for yeah lovely corpse
to and things too so he brings this
vampire corpse Snow White back with him
he brings her back to life or whatever
on death basically and the wife the the
queen wakes up one day and Snow White is
back the prince is with her the prince
has an Army and the queen is
because now she everyone is just
thinking that she's a witch Snow White
accuses her of like trying to kill her
and then we get to the ending where
essentially yeah it's the Salem witch
trial where the queen is burned as a
witch
and Snow White gets the last laugh at
the end so it's it's quite a you know
grisly ending to the story but
technically it's the same course of
events that happens in the original
fairy tale it's just we're seeing this
from the Queen's point of view and of
course Snow White is emphasized as being
this monstrous vampire but
yeah really interesting kind of
retelling here's an intro here's here's
an interesting like example again of of
the intertext here between Neil gaiman's
and the original the original just kind
of announces this part of the story now
it came to pass that a prince entered
these woods and happened upon the
dwarf's house uh skipping some let me
have the coffin I'll give you anything
you want for it we will not sell it for
all the gold in the world the dwarves
answered then he said then give it to me
for I cannot live without being able to
see Snow White I'll honor and respect
her etc etc and then in the Neil Gaiman
version it it kind of um it interprets
this part
um I imagine he's riding through the
woods with blue balls blah blah that's a
paraphrase and here's the quote then I
imagine his little troop riding through
the forest finally coming upon the glass
and crystal Cairn of my stepdaughter
that's her her see-through coffin so
pale so cold naked beneath the glass
little more than a girl and dead I
imagine him negotiating with the little
hairy man and offering them gold and
spices for the lovely corpse under the
crystal Mound so there you can see again
end quote there you can see again how
Neil Gaiman puts these lines back
pointing back to the original but but
setting them in this in this weird
context of um you know this this sexual
tryst he had with the second Queen
before going into the woods and then his
necrophiliac Tendencies he's he's
telling the queen to stay perfectly
still while he has sex with her and then
he and then that doesn't work he finds a
freaking comatose lady in the woods oh
even better right so he sets it in this
in this gross context whereas the
original just kind of announces that
here's here's phase three of the story
now uh so he does it he adds these
things in and I I wanted to point out at
the beginning too right the pin prick
right when you at the beginning of a lot
of these stories uh there's a pin prick
a woman pricks her finger and blood
comes out and she is sort of you know
now symbolized here she is in the cycle
of sexuality she's entered that's what
this story is going to be about here
it's the it's the girl chewing on her
finger and drawing blood and then
sucking the blood that way so he like
takes that and we also mentioned another
one earlier right those little these
little subversions Neil Gaiman does and
so he structures this complicated
instead of a pin prick it's a vampiric
uh blood drawing yeah which is so much
opens up all these other elements in
this story right the necrophilia the
coming back to life the and a lot of it
was already there in the fairy tale as
you kind of point out but Neil Gaiman
just sort of takes it to its darker sort
of places where he thinks about okay we
have this snow white corpse child who
came back from the dead what if she was
just a vampire you know what if the
queen was actually a misunderstood kind
of victim in all of this and I think
beyond the you know the sort of Gothic
you know fun that can be be had with a
story like that is the more serious
question here would be okay Neil Gaiman
and like authors like this sort of
exposing just how easily it is for women
of a certain age or even not even that
old but just you know somebody who was
just maybe older than Snow White to be
demonized to be considered to be a witch
to be instantly kind of turned into the
villain in ways in which we see like was
very common in most Disney movies in
most fairy tales and kind of getting
back again to this question of how much
we've been sort of you know a lot of us
grew up with these ideas of you know
certain kinds of gender roles certain
kinds of beauty standards that even if
we sort of dismiss them once we've kind
of you know stopped watching Disney
movies they've they're still kind of
ubiquitous in the pop culture in
advertising in things like Disney World
and these kinds of imaginaries that sort
of give you this real slash fake version
of you know heightened reality in this
way of like the ideal
younger woman the the sort of more you
know iffy older woman because you don't
really get you know like Barbie
grandmother Edition for example or
whatever you know or even Barbie sort of
you know middle-aged Queen Edition it's
always young Snow White virile so I
think a lot of this stuff beyond the
sort of genre fun that Neil Gaiman is
having with it is is still kind of
interesting and from a question of just
gender roles and beauty standards even
today well I was gonna say too one of
the things I liked about
um
the story too and then I felt like was
kind of impactful is like the ending
where you do where you kind of realize
that you've been he that that she's
because it kind of goes from her
retelling what happened in the past and
then you realize that like at the end
she's like in some is she like on a
stake or in like an oven it's like a uh
for some reason like a kiln of something
and you're just like and she's like it's
getting warmer in here and and it's like
I don't know I just feel like it was it
was so impactful where you're like holy
she's like about to get roasted
right now and she's talking about if
she's covered in Goose oil or like goose
fat yeah goose fat yeah render it's also
interestingly which is what they prepare
for the coming of the winter they
prepare the the goose
so dark and you're like holy she's
like about to be burnt like burned alive
right now and you're just like okay yeah
and it's somebody who's well done yeah
they've you've been with them for the
whole story you know you've kind of seen
everything from their point of view and
by the end you realize the whole story
was being told she's remembering all of
this as she's about to be burned alive
exactly and that's that that's a bit of
a mic drop ending of course from Neil
Gaiman because it's like wow yeah it's
it's quite unsettling yeah the ending of
the original runs like this they put a
pair of iron shoes into burning coals
they were brought forth with tongs and
placed before her this is the evil witch
she was forced to step into the red hot
Shoes and Dance until she fell down dead
so that's that's the ending of the group
version pretty horrible like
yeah no yeah they're not they're they're
not competing for more horrific uh
definitely because these old stories
were pretty weird too especially if
you're coming off the new ones right
with Disney they they sanitize the
endings completely yeah but yeah here
it's being stuffed into an oven which is
not worse than the original ending but
he does kind of describe it in several
paragraphs instead of a single line
which is the original one
but they're just trying to capture the
sort of narrative essence of the story
they're not trying to stylize it as far
as I can tell I don't I don't know what
their method of recording was but you
know they just want to get they just
want to hit the major plot points
they're not interested in in giving you
the feel of a telling of the story as
far as I can see but yeah it could be
wrong about that the original Grim
stories are very kind of simplistic in
the way you point out Eric it's just
kind of like you know this happened and
this happened and that happened and you
know most of them lived happily ever
after the end that's kind of how it goes
but the great thing about the way Neil
Gaiman does it is he really kind of
lingers on the descriptions he kind of
lets you really inhabit this world and
especially I identify with the evil
queen or not so evil in this case who
you know ends up being burned alive and
that's something that creates a lot of
empathy which of course you know these
kinds of stories are always really
valuable and helpful in sort of you know
placing you in the shoes of someone like
that and thinking okay we all know this
story whatever but what if you actually
thought about it from the Queen's
perspective what if you actually you
know thought about these gender Dynamics
from within this sort of world and you
know that's something that I think Neil
Gaiman does quite well especially with
this retelling
and the stuffing of her heart back into
the chest that comes out of nowhere but
that is like um that's an interesting
you know like a bodily reintegration
thing again because like I said like if
you're if you once you read a bunch of
Gothic novels you start to see the
recurring images how they use colors how
they describe body parts how they
describe structures and rooms and
interiors and exteriors and like I was
saying that that one where you know
bodily Parts kind of being like
disembodied body parts disembodied
voices you know like animated corpses
these sorts of contradictory things
that's that's here too right this this
snow white if your skin is that white
you've got to be a corpse but she
reintegrates she gets the heart back
right she didn't eat it that was the LIE
everyone told about her she didn't eat
the hearts but at the end when you know
they Snow White and the new Prince burst
into the room announced they're going to
marry next line is they have told people
bad things about me so that kind of
comes back into a present voice here a
little truth to add Savor to the dish
but mixed with many lies so one of those
lies she didn't eat the heart she's not
a monster she she just hung it over her
bed and and used it to keep track of
Snow White okay weird but but not like
you know not not monstrous right not
like in the original where she sent out
the hunter this was their first solution
the hunter couldn't bear to kill Snow
White she was too innocent and pretty so
he let her kind of run away and instead
murdered uh was it a boar and uh brought
back its organs and she ate the organs
of the boar in the original one and and
that symbolizes her instead of consuming
the sort of heart of the the organs of
who she want she she consumes a beast
her inner Beast her inner monster her
inner animality whatever she consumes it
and goes continues on with her rage and
this one she doesn't eat the heart she
left it there she preserves it in in a
weird way yeah which is the part that
made me a little dubious of like or not
dubious but it made me like doubt The
Narrative a little bit the perspective
because it's like okay like if you know
this girl is a vampire and you have its
heart and we understand how vampire
worlds work why would you not just like
stab it and destroy it to make sure like
it did like that part I was puzzled by
well we we gotta we gotta we gotta
suspend our disbelief a little I know
but because if if the queen is wise and
she was um you know going around the
land talking to gypsies trying to like
get into this occult stuff to figure out
what's going on with this this Walking
Corpse girl presumably she would have
come across someone saying oh you
shouldn't keep his heart in your bedroom
that's mistake number one there get cast
it out no just nobody said that to her
presumably you know yeah right right and
that's also how a lot of these stories
work too it's like there's there's
always something that the hero or
heroine omits which they should have
done which the audience knows they
should have done and they're like ah no
don't go in there or don't pick that up
and in this case don't keep the heart
kill it kill it and that's kind of you
know there's that frustration but it's
like an enjoyable tension right when you
read something or you you know more than
the the character does
and you kind of see this is how this is
why they're going to be this is
it's so smart so her first attack was uh
sorry her first attack was successful
too he has her heart cut out the hunter
did not spare Snow White and bring uh
the organs of a animal sorry go on
yeah I was just gonna say what I thought
what I loved about just like generally
playing with the fact that you know snow
white white skin and then like making
her into a vampire to like kind of
explain why her skin is so white yeah
yeah it's also just pretty genius when
you think about it you're like okay the
whole story was already called Snow
White they already the original story
comments on how white her skin is and
now you're like yeah okay well that
makes kind of satirizing that that
vision of beauty uh red lips and white
skin is like the red lips of a of a kind
of bloated corpse and the white skin of
a dead thing yeah yeah because all the
all the blood is bloodless right be
beauty standards of course have evolved
since then or have moved because
nowadays of course the beauty standard
is actually having tan skin and not just
being you know deathly pale or whatever
but back in the day when this story was
originally sort of being told the ideal
was having very pale skin because it
meant like you were indoors all day you
didn't have to work in the fields or you
were kind of you know you were like an
aristocrat blue-blooded in that sense so
exactly yeah the way that Gaiman kind of
pushes back on that and you know takes
the premier Disney princess image and
makes it like a vampire is is pretty
clever and I think he knows what he's
doing I think he knows what he's kind of
satirizing there
and I mean even today I don't know if
you guys have been to Disney World or
Disneyland or anything like that but
it's it's you can go and have your photo
taken with these kinds of you know
Timeless ideal princesses and it's it's
it's very sort of ingrained in the way
we think about femininity and Beauty
even to this day
yeah for sure I mean I think I
definitely recommend the story to people
like I I really enjoyed it I noticed
online that there's actually a graphic
novel version of it which looks
awesome I was looking at some of the
pictures of it and it looks like really
good so oh yeah he's really good with
pairing up with uh illustrators yeah
yeah yeah maybe maybe uh we can keep
going back and forth but I might fold in
some of the um the feminist reading a
little bit as we go forward too because
it's interesting at least there's we who
is this by this this uh feminist Poetics
text
yeah they wrote a famous study called
the mad woman in the Attic about uh the
sort of feminine characters in 19th
century gothic fiction again and things
like that and what's uh they're yeah
their their take on Snow White is
basically that it represents this sort
of competition again between the older
generation the younger generation
between women but especially in the way
that the the queen herself kind of is is
fighting with elements of Snow White
that she's internalized you know the
sort of uh the male gaze that is always
following her the the mirror telling her
she's no longer fair enough or pretty
enough and that Snow White like she was
once Snow White basically and that she's
now become a little bit older and it's
now the the question of her being
beautiful is starting to really kind of
you know drive her crazy and losing her
beauty every year so
there's a lot of ways to finalize this
kind of stuff and ways in which I think
again just coming back to the idea of
the older woman kind of being seen as
less trustworthy more suspicious in a
lot of these stories I'm I'm always
struck by the some of the discourse even
around like the Hillary Trump election
in 2016 when you know on paper Hillary
was by far the more qualified candidate
you know she didn't quite have Trump's
Charisma but and in the end of course
Trump keeps just tagging her like nasty
woman nasty woman you guys know what I'm
talking about right and everyone who
grows up with you know all these Disney
movies and everything on some level you
have to think they they know what he's
kind of referring to in that way though
the way he's trying to associate Hillary
with a certain kind of you know iffy
older woman so there's a lot of
interesting ways this stuff is still
resonant yeah yeah or you can even think
of the kind of whole demonization of
Monica Lewinsky like everyone even
though she was the one who didn't do
anything wrong but but yeah with these
categories are available and you you can
read these stories and try to you know
again yeah they say you know it
dramatizes uh the the Gilbert and gubar
kind of say that the Grim tale of little
snow white uh dramatizes the essential
but equivocal relationship between the
angel woman and the monster woman and
that that's what I was getting at when I
was saying you know the angel inside of
the monster woman that she's trying to
get rid of
um the stepmother trying to um destroy
this image that her mirror keeps
presenting to her as more beautiful than
her and the angel woman trying to get
rid of the monster woman inside her that
desire to become mature and
self-possessed and active and in control
of the situation
like this story is trying to dramatize
Snow White becoming this perfect
submissive woman the the older lady
becoming the you know perfectly in
control woman but unfortunately for for
their reading or for well for any
reading of this story perhaps the
contradiction lies on the side of the
monster woman because the the angel
woman is going to replace you and even
if you can excise all innocence and
become self-possessed
you as the monster woman are the um what
you're the marked category basically are
you the unmarked category I guess you're
the one who's who's going to be replaced
so in the end it lies so when Neil
Gaiman transforms Snow White into the
evil person then it looks like the um
the the the stepmother the witch is
coming out as the sympathetic character
and not Snow White so that that seemed I
mean that's that's their reading and
then me trying to like splice it with uh
what Neil Gaiman was trying to do right
because because she brings this up
really they bring this up really quickly
in their reading you know transparent
enclosures Windows looking glasses glass
coffins right there those those are
major major symbols in Snow White these
transparent enclosures that are around
women when they're looking out the
window gazing at the woods from their
safe Towers or when they're looking at
themselves and what appears to be some
kind of narcissistic self-obsession or
glass carbons the completely ideal woman
who's beautiful in comatose right like
these sorts of images are so Central and
they do a really good job of reading
these things and that's sort of critical
analysis was of course done before like
the age of smartphones and all kinds of
other you know like screens and you know
glasses that we were much more
surrounded by today and I mean you could
literally you know say like you look at
your phone you check your Instagram
whatever and this question of who is the
fairest of them all it's it's still on
some level operating and driving the
discourse driving this competition in
terms of you know again Beauty as
currency in many ways so
yeah even more relevant that sort of a
reading yeah like a psychoanalytic
reading might suggest there's narcissism
going on with the second Queen and
that's that's her major flaw
um but they disagree with that and I
think we can disagree with that and I
think Neil Gaiman does too right because
of that replacing the mirror with the
heart what but but there's still the
mirror aspect in there I mentioned that
you know she here's the quote there as a
young lass
um in Neil gaiman's version as a young
glass I had worked at the fair I told
fortunes to Fair Growers crying in a
pool of Still Water and later
when I was older in a disc of polished
glass it it's black all silver it's back
all silvered it's a mirror it's a
Looking Glass a gift from a merchant
who's straying horse I had seen in a
pool of ink
so she's using these things to help each
other help she's not using these things
to
look at herself
yeah it's interesting to consider like
how much his inter his retelling is a
more feminist take on this story when we
see the competition between women of
course is only much more severe in his
version but I think that he he does
unpack some of the ways in which the
older Queen certainly is being demonized
and kind of you know slandered as a
witch in ways that I think complicate
the initial sort of fairy tale
presentation in very clever ways
actually yeah and kind of just getting
back again to this question of you know
even historical beauty standards and and
what this this notion of beauty actually
represented it's interesting that some
of these anxieties around you know like
witches and Beauty and the competition
between women there there were these
sorts of uh really kind of crazy
instances of some women actually trying
to you know literally murder the
competition and trying to you know
retain their power and their beauty all
to themselves and they really kind of
you know had this created these scandals
on almost that people were very excited
by and I wanted to sort of you know talk
about so I don't know if you guys have
heard of the story of uh Elizabeth
Bathory for example she was this
medieval Hungarian Countess or something
who was you know fairly young and
Youthful but they found out like later
in her life that she was actually
murdering all these younger girls and
women who are like her servants and
bathing in their blood and trying to
apparently stay youthful by just you
know doing this on this killing spree
and of course you know she was tried and
executed in all of that but this story
about Bathory it was just like it
provoked a sensation and for years after
where people were just like okay you
know who is the next pathori you know
who is this other kind of you know
cannibalistic witch that we have to
watch out for so it's really interesting
how like history becomes mixed with you
know Superstition and Legend and all of
this stuff kind of gets worked into folk
tales past a certain point where people
are still they they feel justified in
having this anxiety at that time about
you know powerful women and questions of
beauty and all of these things so
there are Loosely some interesting like
wild historical you know instances of
this stuff yeah
yeah and and then in the the juniper
tree is a version of little Snow White
in which a boy's mother this is what the
critics are pointing out too the boy's
mother tries to kill him for different
reasons and uh then the the dead boy is
transformed not into a silent art object
that's what that's their kind of key
thing here is that these women are like
um are like the content of a work of art
right and art is not supposed to speak
back art is supposed to stay there
silent for the male contemplative gays
like that's the basic theoretical setup
here so in this other version the The
Dead Boys transformed not into a silent
beautiful thing in a coffin but a
furious Golden Bird who sings a song of
Vengeance against his his uh murder s
and finally crushes her to death and so
on so you can see even the same versions
will put different things in he become
comes with Eagle right and there's
probably much more masculine stuff going
on it's not the queen trying to kill her
first by sending an agent of patriarchy
which is the hunter in the Grim version
and then that failing she tries to get
her with a poisoned comb and then next
she brings her lace and apples and
um so these these feminine objects that
are usually considered dangerous to
become obsessed with right narcissism
but in this case they represent weapons
they represent the tools that a crafty
woman is going to use to ensnare other
less Wily less wise females yeah and
that's a great observation Eric yeah
because the the queen does in the room
version she tries to kill Snow White by
using these tools of associated with
beauty actually yeah so whether it's
like clothing or the hair or the the
comb or these kinds of things so there's
always that underlying subtext about
this being a competition over over
Beauty and who is the fairest of them
all and who does kind of get to sit in
that position by the end of the story
but Ironically in order to even you know
stay and retain that role the queen has
to turn into like this older woman
remember in like the Disney film she has
that transformation so she's actually
she in order to stay beautiful
ironically she has to do like these
horrific things and actually become turn
into this much older woman to even get
there so there's there's a lot of
interesting subtleties there in the way
that this sort of contest is is being
played out that way yeah
yeah these apples are interesting too
because you know it's half white half
red when when the original one there's
there's no such Apple there's no such
sort of thing in the in the game
inversion and the Apple itself of source
is you know goes back to this Primal
symbol of the loss of Innocence right
and Adam and Eve and this this question
of sort of you know maturing and
becoming ashamed of your nakedness or of
your body so Snow White eating eating
the Apple you can also kind of
psychoanalyze that of course as her kind
of you know transitioning into a
Womanhood but of course that's what
kills her because the queen is trying to
prevent that from happening she doesn't
want her to kind of you know take her
place in that way so yeah the Apple
itself is a very loaded image or symbol
in that way even in the original story
yeah yeah yeah so you Apple the the
apple of Adam and Eve right the the
eaves or Eve's original Temptation kind
of thing that's that's that's definitely
in there as as a symbol of that too yeah
yeah and the Apple's half white and half
red so it represents you know she the
the the old Queen in Disguise eats the
white half to prove that it's not
poisonous but of course she put all the
poison in the red half and gives the fun
red pretty half to the girl who eats it
and falls into the coma so she's been
sort of ensnared by this this this
Timeless female weapon but this time
directed against another female instead
of against Adam the the man
but it but it still retains its Force as
a kind of um tool of of feminine
deception here which is
you know obviously punished at the end
of the Grim story because she dies but
it's not so it's punished by Gaiman too
at the end but but again like I said I
think the empathy still lies with the
with the older Queen and not the crazy
young vampires hmm
maybe we should segue into an ending
yeah I think it's a good place to wrap
it's a good discussion I mean I was kind
of listening to you guys there at the
end because like kind of literary
interpretation isn't really my forte but
I enjoyed listening and uh I mean it'll
be interesting if again we're all
probably going to check out the Barbie
movie at some point
it'll be interesting to see uh how much
of the pills video how much of this
discussion kind of informs our uh our
take on that yeah
yeah I guess maybe maybe my girlfriend
will make me see it uh
it's supposed to be a satire right it's
supposed to be a satire of of Barbie
well I think it's exactly I think it's
exactly what uh pills said that
oh no it's supposed to come out tomorrow
so but maybe there's Advanced screenings
yeah
um but it's exactly what I think based
on the reviews what pills said which is
you know some kind of a movie that plays
with the idea of kind of like on
unmasking the idealization of Barbie and
bringing Barbie to like have an
existential crisis and kind of face the
real world or something like that
uh so it's probably not gonna be because
Barbie is kind of Frozen in time it's
like a comedy probably gonna we're gonna
miss the budding sexuality aspect of
these stories probably because yeah I
don't think that movie is going to be
quite as revisionist with Barbie as Neil
Gaiman was with Snow White
well also like what is the story of
Barbie Barbie doesn't even really have a
story well it's a bunch of little
stories that sell her sell her different
outfits basically like give her little
personalities around me wait you know
you you play with Barbie in her
dollhouse and you create the story
that's the appeal you know there's a
thousand Barbies out there they all have
you know unique individual stories and
and it follows cultural tastes right so
you know you'll see Barbie in the
workplace now the doctor Barbie the
professional Barbie the Barbie in the
suit right it will it's more amorphous
it doesn't have one sort of story her
coming of age is basically just getting
new outfits that are more that are less
traditionally feminine but Barbie is I
mean much like these stories Barbie is
literally framed again like they were
saying in the opening right transparent
enclosures well how do you buy a Barbie
you buy her in a box with a plastic film
on the front of it she is literally
always free named she is an art object
just like Snow White in the coffin she
is an art object and you get to bring
her to life with your kiss or maybe
something less sexual but you get to do
that with Barbie She's but she's
literally Frozen in time she never ages
she was never born and she's never gonna
mature sexually because she's kind of
already there apparently the movie plays
with those things but who know who knows
anyway this isn't a podcast about Barbie
yeah I won't go on to a new topic don't
worry yeah Eric has a I feel like lately
especially Eric just has this tendency
to just like start a new topic when
we're about to wrap up and I'm like
tired I just want to go and he's like oh
what about this what about this yeah
right on the end I switch on I switch on
oh my God yeah thanks for listening and
uh that's it
thanks guys absolutely good talk till
next time or you can stop recording on
your end
okay
[Music]